I'd like to welcome to the show now the
journalist Isabelle Hardman who's spoken
very openly about her own mental health
problems and the impact that's had on
her ability to work thanks so much for
coming in this evening and it's been
well-documented you're a print
journalist your battle with mental
health problems and you were fortunate
in that your employer was very
supportive but your colleagues are very
supportive and I'm pleased to say you've
been able to return to work in full
health
yeah and how unusual is that kind of
success I think it's quite unusual still
I've been so lucky that the spectator
were so supportive of me when I was
trying to stay in work and then when
actually I realized that I needed to
take full sick leave for initially for
two months so then came back too early
which was my decision not my works
decision and I then had to take another
two months off and have come back on a
phased return over well since June
actually where I've been adding more
hours each week and just taking on more
responsibilities and I'm not fully
better yet but I'm well enough to work
which is wonderful because Adi genuinely
loved my job and it doesn't actually
help to be at home feeling like your
life is passing you by so to have had
the help and support and the sort of
regular check-ins I get from my Human
Resources Department for instance has
been so important obviously this story
has been discussed great deal in the
media today and I've seen from my
Twitter feed another journalist this
evening announcing that she's gone off
on sick leave but saying she has this
incredible sense of guilt because she's
not at home with her head down the
toilet there's no tangible sign to the
outside world that she's ill how hard is
it for people to stand there and to be
honest in the workplace and say I'm not
well enough to work even though to
anybody else to the naked eye they may
well look it I think people are getting
much better at understanding that you
just cannot see mental illness I mean
sometimes you can obviously see signs of
distress people can physically sort of
become hunched over when they're
particularly anxious and depressed but
most of the time you can't and actually
a lot of sick leave if used well is
about being outside and about getting
out of the house and doing things to
help you as you recover so I did lots of
horse riding for instance when I was on
sick leave because it's something that
really calms me down I could afford to
do it but it was a really important
thing that my doctor was insistent that
I kept
doing now to the outside world this must
have looked like I was having a lovely
time sort of sauntering around Richmond
Park but it was a really important part
of my recovery and slowing my mind down
and it was one of the things that got me
back to work along with the medication
and the therapy when do you think people
gonna start taking this seriously ninety
nine billion pounds a year to the
economy that's almost double the brexit
bill the dreaded brexit bill that
everyone's so afraid of I mean it's
costing a great deal of money yes this
report today has made such a compelling
case hasn't it for employers taking this
seriously I think employers are
realizing that if they lose an employee
to a mental health problem first it's
not their employees fault it's just the
same as if they succumb to a physical
illness but also they lose they lose
money as a business and that's really
important for them to work to stop
someone having to go onto sick leave in
the first place but also to get them
back and I think that's important I
think this report is really good today
but the fact is that people can't access
mental health treatment in this country
so all of the therapy that I had was
private and I was able to afford it for
a while out of my savings but eventually
a charity connected to work paid for my
counseling sessions because I couldn't
afford to keep them and do you think
that companies should have a
responsibility if their staff members
are off on sick leave
given that the government is infamously
not paying enough to pay for this kind
of treatment and not everyone has access
to private health care should this be
received well it's primarily the
government's responsibility and the
thing that I worry about as a political
journalist is that Theresa May is coming
out with very warm words and instructing
employers to do this stuff and the other
when actually she is the prime minister
and she does have albeit limited power
to change things as she could make much
more of a focus on spending on mental
health on some different legislative
changes more money in the future more of
a focus actually on conditions that
aren't just anxiety and depression
because if you have for instance
borderline personality disorder
post-traumatic stress disorder those
therapies are even harder to get on the
NHS than the talking therapies that I
think it's only about 15% of people are
actually able to access at the moment
that's 15% of people who relieve them
yeah okay as well have been really good
to talk to you thank you
and